we we started off with the simple
methods for learning stuff then we
talked to Lou about learning a purchase
and learning that we're vaguely inspired
by the fact that our heads are stuffed
with neurons so that we seem to evolved
from primates then we talked about
looking at the problem and address the
issue of phonology and how it's possible
to learn concepts but now we're coming a
full circle back to the beginning and
thinking about how to divide up a space
with decision boundaries but where as
you do it with a neural net or a nearest
neighbors or a ID tree those are very
simple ideas that work very often today
we're going to talk about a very
sophisticated idea that still has a
simple implementation so this needs to
be in the tool bag of every civilized
person this is about support vector
machines an idea that was developed well
I want to talk to you today about how
ideas develop actually because you look
at stuff like this in a book and you
think well vladimir vapnik just to
figure this out one Saturday afternoon
when it was the weather was too bad to
go outside that's not how it happens it
happens very differently I'll talk to
you a little bit about that nice thing
about about things that were great
things that we're done by people are
still alive as you can ask them how they
did it you can't do that with Fourier
you can't say to Fourier how did you do
it did you dream it up on a Saturday
afternoon but you can call vapnik on the
phone and asking questions that's the
stuff I'm going to talk about towards
the end of the hour well it's all about
decision boundaries and now we have
several techniques that we can use to
draw some decision boundaries and here's
the same problem and if we drew decision
boundaries in here we might get
something that would look like
maybe this if we were doing a
nearest-neighbor approach and if we're
doing ID trees would just draw in a line
like that and if we're doing neural nets
well you know you can put in a lot of
straight lines wherever you like with a
neural net depending on how its trained
up or if you just simply go in there and
design it so you could you could do that
if you wanted and you would think that
after people been working on the source
stuff for 50 or 75 years that there
wouldn't be any tricks in the bag left
and that's when everybody got surprised
because around the early 90s vladimir
vapnik introduced the ideas i'm about to
talk to you about
so what vapnik says is something like
this here you have a space and you have
some negative examples and you have some
positive examples how do you divide the
positive examples from the negative
examples and what he wants to do what he
says we want to do is want to we want to
draw a straight line but which straight
line is the question well we want to
draw a straight line but would this be a
good straight line when it went up like
that probably not so hot how about one
that's just right here well that's might
separate them but seems awfully close to
the negative examples so maybe what we
ought to do is we ought to draw our
straight line in here sort of like this
and that line is drawn with a view
toward putting in the widest street that
separates the positive samples from the
negative samples that's why I call it
the widest Street approach so that makes
way of putting in the decision boundary
is to put in a straight line but in
contrast with the way ID tree puts in a
straight line it tries to put the line
in in such a way as the separation
between the pause and the negative
examples that's that Street is as wide
as possible all right so you might think
to do that in a UROP project and then
let it go with that you know what's the
big deal so what we got to do is we're
going to kind of go through why it's a
big deal so first of all we kind of like
to think about how you would make a
decision rule that would use that
decision boundary so what I'm going to
ask you to imagine is that we've got a
vector of any length you like
constrained to be perpendicular to the
medium or if you like perpendicular to
the gutters it's perpendicular to the
media line of the street
all right strong in such a way that
that's true you we don't know anything
about its length yet then we also have
some unknown say right here and we have
a vector that points to it like so so
now what we're really interested in is
whether or not that unknown is on the
right side of the street or on the left
side of the street so what we want to do
is we want to project that vector u down
on the one it's perpendicular to the
street
because then we'll have the distance in
this direction or a number that's
proportional to the distance in this
direction and and the further out we go
the closer we'll get to being on the
right side of the street or the right
side of the street is not the correct
side but actually the right side of the
street so what we can do is we can say
let's take W and dot it with u and
measure whether or not that number is
equal to or greater than some constant C
so remember that the dot product is
taking the projection onto W and the
bigger that projection is the further
out along this line the projection will
lie and eventually be so big that the
projection crosses the median line of
the street and we'll say it must be a
positive sample
or we could say without loss of
generality that the dot product plus
some constant B is equal to or greater
than zero if that's true then it's a
positive sample so that's our decision
rule and this is the first in several
elements that we're going to have to
line up to understand what this idea
called support vector machines so that's
the decision rule and trouble is we
don't know what constant weight to use
and we don't know which W to use either
we know that W has to be perpendicular
to the median line of the street but
there are lots of w's that are
perpendicular to the median line of the
street because it can be of any length
so we don't have any concern of
constraint here to fix a particular B or
a particular W are you with me so far
yeah all right so what we're going to do
next and this by the way we get just by
saying that C equals minus B what we're
going to do next is we're going to lay
on some additional constraints whether
you toward putting enough constraint on
the situation that we can actually
calculate calculate a B and a W so what
we're going to say is this that is if we
if we look at this quantity that we're
checking out to be greater than or less
than zero to make our decision then what
we're going to do is we're going to say
that if we take that vector W and we
take the dot product of that with some X
plus some positive sample now this is
not an unknown it's a positive sample if
we take those the dot product of those
two vectors and we add B just like in
our decision rule we're going to want
that to be equal to or greater than 1 so
in other words
you can be an unknown anywhere in this
street and be just a little bit a
greater or just a little bit less than
zero but if you're a positive sample
we're going to insist that this decision
function gives a value of one or greater
likewise if w dotted with some negative
sample is provided to us then we're
going to say that that has to be equal
to or less than minus one all right so
if you're a minus sample like one of
these two guys or any minus sample that
a lot may lie down here this function
that gives us the decision rule must
return minus one or less so there's a
separation of distance here of minus one
to plus one for all of the samples so
that's cool but it we're not quite done
because I don't know this is carrying
around two equations like this it's kind
of a pain so we're going to do is we're
going to introduce some another variable
to make things make life a little easier
like many things we do and when we
develop this kind of stuff introducing
this variable is not something that God
says has to be done it's just a minor
thought what is it it's a we introduce
this additional stuff to do what to make
the mathematics more convenient it's a
mathematical convenience so what we're
going to do is we're going to introduce
a variable Y sub I such that Y sub I is
equal to plus 1/4 plus samples
and minus one negative samples alright
so for each sample we're going to have a
value for this new quantity we've
introduced Y and the value of y is going
to be determined by whether it's a
positive sample or a negative sample
it's a positive sample it's going to be
plus one the situation up here and it's
going to be minus one for this situation
down here so what we're going to do with
this first equation is we're going to
multiply it by Y sub I and that is now X
sub I plus B is equal to or greater than
one and then you know we're going to do
we're going to multiply the left side of
this equation by we're going to multiply
the left side of this equation by Y sub
I as well so the second equation becomes
y sub I times X of I plus B and now what
does that do over here we multiplied
this guy times minus one so it used to
be the case that that was less than
minus one so if we multiply it by minus
one that has to be greater than plus one
oops the two equations are the same
because of that introduced this this
little mathematical convenience so now
we can say that Y sub I times X sub I
plus B well what we're going to do right
now you leave out a W I'm sorry thank
you yeah I wouldn't got very far with
that
so that's dotted with W dotted with W
take away those are all vectors I'll
pretty soon forget to put the little
vector marks on there but you know what
I mean
you plus B and now let me bring that
that one over to the left side that's
equal to R greater than zero
all right now with Bret correction I
think everything's okay but we're going
to take one more step and and and we're
going to say that y sub I times X sub I
times W plus B minus one you know it's
always got to be equal to a greater than
zero but what I'm going to say is that
for for X sub I in a gutter so they're
always going to be greater than zero but
we're going to say we're going to add
the additional constraint that it's
going to be exactly zero for all of the
samples that end up in the you know in
the gutters here of the street so the
value of that expression is going to be
exactly zero for that sample exactly
sorry zero for this sample in this
sample not zero for that sample it's
going to be greater than one all right
so that's step number two
and this is step number one okay so now
we've just got some expressions that
talk about some constraints now what are
we trying to do here I forgot oh I
remember now we're trying to get we're
trying to figure out how to arrange for
the line to be such that the street
separating the pluses from the minuses
as wide as possible so maybe we better
figure out how we can express the
distance between the two gutters
that's just a repeat our drawing we got
some minuses here that pluses out here
and we got gutters that are going down
here and now we've got a vector here to
a minus and we've got a vector here to a
plus so that's a call that X plus and
this X minus so what's the what's the
width of the street I don't know yet but
what we can do is we can take the
difference of those two vectors and that
will be a vector that looks like this
right so that's X plus minus X minus so
now if I only had a unit normal that's
normal to the median line of the street
if it's a unit normal that I could just
take the dot product of that unit normal
and this difference factor and that
would be the width of the street right
so in other words if I had a unit vector
in that direction
and I could just dot the two together
and that would be the width of the
street so let me write that down before
I forget so the width is equal to X plus
minus X minus okay that's the difference
vector and now I got to multiply it by a
unit vector but wait a minute
I said that that W is a normal right W
is a normal so what I can do is I can
multiply this times W and then we'll
divide by the magnitude of W and that
will make any unit vector so that that
that dot product not another product
that dot product is in fact a scalar and
it's the width of the street
doesn't do us much good because it
doesn't look like we get much out of it
oh but I don't know let's see what can
we get out of it oh t you know we got
this equation over here this this
equation that constrains the samples
that lie on the gutter so if we have a
positive sample for example then this is
plus one and we have this equation so it
says that X plus times W is equal to o 1
minus B see I'm just taking this part
here this vector here and I'm dotting it
with X plus so that's this piece right
here Y is 1 for this kind of sample so
I'll just take the one and the B back
over to the other side I've got 1 minus
B ok well we can do the same trick with
X minus if we've got a negative sample
then Y sub I is negative that gives us
our negative W times dotted with X of I
and now we take this stuff back over to
the right side and we get 1 minus B 1
plus B all right so that all license is
to rewrite this thing as 2 over the
magnitude of W how did I get there well
I decided I was going to enforce this
constraint I noted that the width of the
street has got to be this difference
vector times a unit vector then I use
the constraint to plug back some values
here and it discovered to my delight and
amazement that the width of the street
is 2 over the magnitude of W espera
yeah let's see if I've got a minus here
then that makes that minus and then the
B is minus I'm gonna take the vo the
other side it becomes plus no I'm sorry
this this expression here is 1 minus 1
plus B okay trust me it works I haven't
got my legs all tangled up like last
Friday quite not yet anyway
it's possible there's gonna be a lot of
algebra here eventually so this finally
here this is miracle number three this
is quantity here is the width of the
street and what we're trying to do is
we're trying to maximize that right so
we want to maximize 2 over the magnitude
of W if we're to get the widest street
under the constraints that we've decided
that we're going to work with all right
so that means that it's okay to maximize
1 over W instead we just drop the
constant and that means that it's okay
to minimize the magnitude of W right and
that means that it's okay to minimize
1/2 times the magnitude of W squared
right Brett why did I do that why did I
multiply by 1/2 and square
let's mathematically convenient thank
you so this is a this is point number
three in the development so where do we
go we decided that was there going to be
our decision rule we're going to see
which side of the line
we decided to constrain the situation so
that the value of the decision rule is
+1 in the gutters for the positive
samples and minus one and the gutters
for the negative samples and then we
discovered that maximizing the width of
the street led us to an expression like
that which we wish to maximize how
should we take a break should we get
coffee too bad we can't do that in this
kind of situation but we would if we
could and I'm sure when Batna got to
this point he went out for coffee so now
we back up and we say well let's let
these expressions start developing into
a song not like that that's vapid
speaking of that Nick what song is it
going to sing we've got an expression
here that would like to find the minimum
of the extremum of and we've got some
constraints here that we would like to
honor what are we going to do
let me put what we're going to do to you
in the form of a puzzle is it got
something to do with legendre as it got
something to do with Laplace or does it
have something to do with the grunge
she says Lagrange actually all three
were said to be on for EA's doctor'll
Defense Committee must have been quite
an exam but we want to talk about
Lagrange because we're going to we got a
situation here
this 1801 1802 1802 we learned in 1802
that if we're going to find the extremum
of a function with constraints then
we're going to have to use the Lagrange
multipliers that will give us a new
expression which we can maximize or
minimize without thinking about the
constraints anymore
that's how the Grimes multipliers work
so this brings us to miracle number four
piece of the developmental piece number
four and it sort of works like this
we're going to say that L the thing
we're going to try to maximize in order
to maximize the width of the street is
equal to one-half times the magnitude of
that vector W squared - and now we've
got to have a summation over all the
constraints and each of those
constraints is going to have a
multiplier alpha sub I and then we write
down two constraint and when we write
down two constraint there it is up there
but I've got to be hyper careful here
because otherwise I'll get lost in the
algebra so the constraint is y sub I
times vector W dotted with the vector X
sub I plus B and now I've got a closing
parenthesis a minus one that's the end
of my constraint like so I sure hope
I've got that right because I'll be in
deep trouble if that's wrong so
everybody anybody see any bugs in that
that looks right doesn't it we got two
we got we got the original thing we're
trying to work with now we've got
Lagrange's all multiplied with respect
to that constraint up there where each
constraint is constrained to be 0 well
there's a little bit of mathematical
sleight of hand here because in the end
the ones that are going to be 0 the
Lagrange's here the ones that are going
to be nonzero are going to be the ones
connected with vectors that lie on the
gutter the rest are going to be 0 but in
any event we can pretend that this is
what we're doing and then we've got to
find a Mac I don't care whether it's a
maximum or a minimum I've lost track but
we're going to do is we're kind of try
to find an extreme of that so what do we
do
what is 1801 teach us about
finding maximum well we got to find the
derivatives and set them to zero and
then after we've done that a little bit
of that manipulation we're going to see
a wonderful song start to emerge so
let's see if we can do it let's take the
partial of L the Lagrangian with respect
to the vector W oh my god how do you
differentiate with respect to a vector
turns out that it has a form that looks
exactly like differentiating with
respect to a scalar and the way you
prove that to yourself is you just
expand everything in terms of all the
vectors components you differentiate
those with respect to what you're
differentiating with respect to and
everything turns out the same so what
you get when you differentiate this with
respect to the vector W is to comes down
and we have just magnitude of W how's it
the magnitude of W yeah
like so the magnitude well I think that
we got it
it's not the magnitude of it just W like
so no magnitude involved then we got a W
over here that we got we go so we got
differentiate this part of it with
respect to W as well but that part's a
lot easier because all we have there is
an W it's not there's no magnitudes not
raised to any power
so what's W multiplied by well it's
multiplied by x and y sub I and alpha
sub I right so that means that this
expression this derivative of the
Lagrangian with respect to W is going to
be equal to W minus the sum of alpha sub
I Y sub I X sub I and that's how I got
to be set to zero and that implies the W
is equal to the sum of some alpha I some
scalars times this minus 1 or plus one
variable times X sub I over I
and now the math is beginning to sing
because it tells us that the vector W is
a linear sum of the samples some sub all
the samples are some of the samples it
didn't have to be that way it could have
been raised to a power there could have
been a logarithm all sorts of horrible
things could have happened when we did
this but when we did this we discovered
that W is going to be equal to a linear
sum of these vectors here some of the
vectors in the sample set and I say sum
because we're for some alpha will be
zero all right so this is something that
we want to take note of as something
important now of course we've got
differentiate L with respect to anything
else that might vary so we got to
differentiate L with respect to B as
well so what's that going to be equal to
well there's no B in here so that makes
no contribution this part here doesn't
have a begin it so that makes no
contribution there's no B over here so
that makes no contribution so we get
alpha I times y sub I times B that has a
contribution so that's going to be the
sum of alpha I times y sub I then we
differentiate we're differentiating with
respect to B so that disappears there's
a minus sign here and that's equal to
zero or that implies that the sum of the
alpha I times y sub I is equal to zero
hmm that looks like that might be
helpful somewhere now it's time for more
coffee by the way these coffee periods
take months you stare at it you work on
something else you got to worry about
your finals and you think about it some
more
and eventually you come back from coffee
and do the next thing
who what is the next thing well we still
got this expression that we're trying to
find the minimum for and you know you
say to yourself this is really a job for
the numerical analysts those guys know
about this sort of stuff because of that
little power in there that's where this
is a so-called quadratic optimization
problem so this point you would be
inclined to hand this problem over to
numerical analysts they'll come back in
a few weeks with an algorithm you
implement the algorithm and maybe things
work maybe they don't converge but any
case you don't worry about it but we're
not going to do that because we want to
do a little bit more math because we're
interested in stuff like this we're
interested in the fact that the decision
vector is a linear sum of the samples so
we're going to work a little harder on
this stuff and in particular now that
we've got an expression for W this one
right here we're going to plug it back
in there and we're going to plug it back
in here and see what happens to that
thing we're trying to find the extremum
of
it was a very kind of relaxed taking
deep breath this isn't actually this is
the easiest part this is just some just
doing a little bit of the algebra so the
thing we're trying to maximize or
minimize is equal to one half and now we
got to have the the magnitude of those
the magnitude we're going to have this
vector here in their inner twice all
right because we're multiplying it to
you two together so let's see we've got
from that expression up there one of
those w's will just be the sum of the
alpha I times y sub I times the vector X
sub I and then we got the other one too
so that's just going to be the sum of
alpha now I want to keep things I'm
going to actually eventually squish
those two sums together into a double
summation so I have to keep the index
and straight so I'm just going to write
that as alpha sub J Y sub J X sub J so
those are my two vectors I'm going to
take the dot product for those that's
the first piece right well this is this
is not this is hard
so minus and now the next term
looks like alpha Y sub I X sub I times W
so we've got a whole bunch of of these
we get a sum of alpha I times y sub I
times X sub I and then that gets
multiplied times W so we'll put this
like this I have some of alpha J Y sub J
X sub J in there like that
and then that's a dot product or that
constant that wasn't as bad as I thought
now I've got to deal with the next term
the alpha I times y sub I times B so
that's my is that a that's a minus sum
of alpha I times y sub I times B and
then to finish it off we have plus the
sum of alpha sub I that's that minus one
up there minus one in front of the
summation such as the sum of the alphas
are you with me so far just a little
algebra it looks good I think I think I
haven't left it yet let's see alpha I
times y sub I times B B is a constant so
pull that out there and then I just got
the sum of alpha alpha sub I times y sub
I oh that's good that's zero and now so
so for every one of these terms we dot
it with this whole expression so that's
just like taking this thing here and
dotting those two things together right
oh but that's just the same thing we've
got here right so now what we can do is
we can say that we can rewrite this
Lagrangian as you got we got that sum of
alpha I that's the positive element and
then we got we got one of these and a
half of these so that's minus one half
and now I'll just convert that whole
works into a double sum over both I and
J of alpha I times alpha J times y sub I
times y sub J times X sub I dotted the
Nexen J we should with do a lot of
trouble to get there but now we've got
it and we know that what we're trying to
do is we're trying
find a maximum of that expression and
that's the one we're going to hand off
to the numerical analysts so if we're
going to hand this off to the numerical
analysts anyway why did I go to all this
trouble good question why do you have
any idea why I went to all this trouble
because I wanted to find out the
dependence of this expression has wanted
selling me as I'm translating as I go
she's telling me in Romania I want to
find what this maximization depends on
with respect to the these of these these
vectors the X the sample vectors and
what I've discovered is that the
optimization depends only on the dot
product of pairs of samples necessarily
want to keep in mind that's why I put it
in royal purple now up here so so let's
see let's this what do we call that one
up there that's two I guess this will
call this piece here three this piece
here is four and out I had one more
piece because I want to take that that W
and not only stick it back into that
Lagrangian I want to stick it back into
the decision rule so now my decision
rule with this expression for W is going
to be W plugged into that thing so the
decision rule is going to look like the
sum of alpha I times y sub I times X sub
I dotted with the unknown vector like so
and we're going to subtract I guess ad B
and way to say if that's greater than or
equal to zero then plus
so you know you see why the math math is
begin to sing to us now because now we
discover that the decision rule also
depends only of the on the dot product
of those sample vectors and the unknown
so the total there the total dependence
of all of the math on the dot products
all right and now I hear a whisper
someone is saying I don't believe the
mathematicians can do it I don't think
those numerical analysts can find the
optimization I want to be sure of it
give me an ocular proof so I'd like to
run a demonstration of it
okay there's our sample problem when I
started the hour out with now if if the
optimization algorithm doesn't get stuck
on a local maximum or something it
should find a nice straight line
separating those two guys defining the
widest street between the minuses and
the pluses so in just a couple of steps
you can see down at step 11 it's decided
that it's done as much as I can on the
optimization and it's got three alphas
and you can see that the two negative
the two negative samples both figure
into the solution the weights on the the
Lagrangian multipliers are given by
those little yellow bars so the two
negatives participate in the solution it
has one of the positives but the other
positive doesn't so it has a zero weight
so everything worked out well now I said
as long as it doesn't get stuck on a
local maximum guess what those
mathematical friends of ours can tell us
and prove to us that this thing is a
convex space that means it can never get
stuck in a local maximum so in contrast
with things like neural nets where where
you have a plague of local Maxima this
guy never gets stuck on a local maximum
let's try some other examples there's
two vertical points no surprises there
right when you say well maybe it can't
deal with diagonal points
sure it can how about this thing here
yeah it only needed two of the points
since any two of those pluses any two a
plus or minus will define the street
let's try this guy Oh
what I think will happen here well we're
screwed right because it's literally
unseparable bad news so in situations
where it's linearly unseparable the
method the the mechanism struggles and
eventually will just slow down and you
truncate it because it's not making any
progress you see the red light the red
dots there are ones that it got wrong so
you say well too bad for our side
doesn't look like it's all that good
anyway but then a powerful idea comes to
the rescue when stuck switched to
another perspective so if we don't like
the space that we're in because it
Purdue gives us samples that are not
linearly acceptable linearly separable
then we can say shoot here's our space
here are two points here are two other
points we can't separate them but if we
can somehow get them into another space
maybe we can separate them because they
look like this and the other space and
they're easy to separate so what we need
then is a transformation that will take
us from the space we're in into a space
where things are more convenient so
we're going to call that transformation
fee of the vector X that's the
transformation and now here's the reason
for all the magic I said that the
maximization only depends on dot
products so all I need to do the
maximization is that is the
transformation of one vector dotted with
the transformation of another vector
like so that's what I need to maximize
or to find the maximum owner
on in order to recognize where do they
go underneath the chalkboard
oh yes here it is to recognize all I
need is dot products - so for that one I
need fee of X dotted with fee of you and
just to make this a little bit more
consistent a notation I'll call that X J
and this X Ally and that's x Emma those
are the quantities I need in order to do
it so that means that if I have a
function let's call it K of X sub I and
X sub J that's equal to V of X sub I
dotted with V of X 2 J then I'm done
this is what I need I don't actually
need this all I need is that function K
which happens to be called a kernel
function which provides me with the dot
product of those two vectors in another
space I don't have to know the
transformation into the other space and
that's the reason that this stuff is a
miracle
so what are some of those what are some
of the kernels that are popular one is
the linear kernel that says that u
dotted with with B plus 1 to the F is
such such a kernel because it's got u in
it and V in it the two dotted the two
vectors and this is what the dot product
is in the other space so that's one
choice another choice is a kernel that
looks like this e to the minus let's
take the dot product of those two oh the
difference of those two guys let's take
the magnitude of that and divide it by
some Sigma that's a second kind of
kernel that we can use so let's go back
and see if we can solve this problem by
transforming it into another space where
we have another perspective so let's
that's the that's it that's a that's
that's another kernel and so sure we can
and that's the answer when transformed
back into the original space we could
also try doing that with the so-called
radial basis kernel that's the one with
the exponential in it we can learn on
that one boom no problem so we've got a
general method that's convex and
guaranteed to produce a global solution
we've got a mechanism that easily allows
us to transform this into another space
so it works like a charm
of course it doesn't remove all possible
problems look at that exponential thing
here if we choose a sigma that is small
enough then those Sigma's are
essentially shrunk right around the
sample points and we can get overfitting
so it doesn't immunize it against
overfitting but does immunizes against
local maxima and does it provide us with
a general mechanism for doing a
transformation into another space with a
better perspective now the history
lesson all this stuff feels fairly new
it feels like it's younger than you are
here's the history of it that make
emigrated from the Soviet Union to the
United States in about 1991 nobody ever
heard of this stuff before he emigrated
he actually had done this work on the
basic support vector idea it is PhD
thesis at Moscow University in the early
60s but it wasn't possible for him to do
anything with it because they didn't
have any computers that he could try
anything out with so he spent the next
25 years at some oncology Institute in
the Soviet Union doing applications
somebody from Bell Labs discovers him
veidt's them over to the United States
where he subsequently decides to
emigrate in 1992 or there abouts that
makes submits three papers to the to
nips the neural information processing
systems journal all of them were
rejected he's still sore about it but
it's motivated
so around 1992 1993 Bell Labs was
interested in handwritten character
recognition and in neural nets vapnik
thinks that neural nets but would be a
good word to use I can think of the
vernacular but he thinks that they're
not very good so he bets a colleague a
good dinner that support vector machines
will eventually do better handwriting
recognition than neural nets and it's a
dinner bet right it's not that big a
deal but as Napoleon said it's amazing
what a soldier will do for a bit of
ribbon so that makes colleague who's
working on this on this on this problem
of handwritten recognition decides to
try a support vector machine with a
kernel in which n equals 2
just slightly nonlinear works like a
charm as it was it's the first time
anybody tried a kernel that make
actually had the idea in his thesis but
never thought it was very important as
soon as it was shown to work in the
early 90s on the problem handwriting
recognition patnik resuscitated the idea
of the kernel began to develop it and
became an essential part of the whole
approach of using support vector
machines so the main point about this is
that it was 30 years in between the
concept and anybody ever hearing about
it it was 30 years between badniks
understanding of kernels and his
appreciation of their importance and
that's the way things often go great
ideas followed by long periods of
nothing happening followed by an
epiphanies moment when the original idea
is seen to have great power with just a
little bit of a twist and then the world
ever looks back and Babinec who nobody
ever heard of until the early 90s
becomes famous for something that
everybody knows about today who does
machine learning
you